[Music]
investor of ever news yachtsman my thick
lips thick lips sink ships oh yeah yeah
the thickest Jo a dream job is paying
100 an hour to play with dogs 100 an
hour ya gonna pay good - yeah I'm Quinn
yes I can play with dogs all [ __ ] day
used what if you started to do it like
and you're doing it for a couple months
and then you're like oh those dogs it
depends on how hard you got to play with
dog I see because if it's tiring then I
can see it being really really like I
don't want to go into work today
cuz fetch is really fun because the dog
is so excited about it it's really funny
the water doofy asses like chases ball
goats and you throw it for four hours
and you're like god damn the energy this
dog's energy isn't coming down the way I
pictured it was like that scene from
Sound of Music where she's running up
the hill and [ __ ] running around and
it's like me being chased by dogs on the
[ __ ] open plain you know I don't like
it when dogs know how to play fetch
because they don't know when the stuff
they don't want to stop yeah [ __ ] a
Brandon's dog Oh Ron Annan I [ __ ]
love that dog but that fool could play
fetch till he dies he doesn't care about
anything
yeah that's all he cares about like my
dog tricks eat we caught her one time
she ate an entire Costco pizza and she
ate the whole [ __ ] guy and she was
like this big
oh [ __ ] she's just looking on the ground
on her side and if I put more foot in
front of her she would ate that - dude
our dog did that one so he had the cops
go pizza in a box and we made the stupid
mistake of leaving it where he can reach
it on the comm so we're still unloading
the car and then as soon as we're ready
to eat our pizza we grab the box and the
[ __ ] box is empty this bull had the
audacity to pull the entire pizza out
and then just leave the box so dude he
did throw away the box that [ __ ] it
wasn't even wet there was nothing there
was no trace of a dog ever being he ate
the whole thing
he ate the whole thing is that when you
blame him he was like honey knows be
true right reason why I knew is because
at this time we it serves Tyson and my
dog patches and when they did something
bad
Hatch's would always there at the wall
loaf made eye contact with you I mean
yes sir
Tyson made eye contact with you he would
be like this you think patches ate some
- probably self-aware that they're so
[ __ ] guilty but they're so Catholic
that it's like oh hey I know you and
they're meeting like you just keep going
I don't know you're talking about they
would maybe get away with some [ __ ] yes
yeah dogs are so [ __ ] smart annoying
that's so funny they're [ __ ] guilty
please it's called mutts cain't
canine Cantina and it's in Dallas Texas
and so they're saying that they've just
opened a brand new location in Fort
Worth and they want to have a pup turn
like a puppy in turn oh cool to work
there and they'll be getting paid $100
per hour to pet the dogs that come so
this place mutts
it's pretty much a restaurant and bar
whoa a park attached to it
oh my smells so bad that's so true oh
they had like this hole and then they
also do vents where you do like dog yoga
like you'll go with your dog or they do
movie nights where they play dog movies
what's this place called I mean where is
it how come all the cool places are
outside of California because it's
cheaper to start up businesses here so
like iíve been to dog parks in Texas and
they're not like out here because it
actually rains and then there's you know
and when they don't have millions of
dogs compared to us so our dog parks
smell for [ __ ] miles yeah like it
smells like [ __ ] [ __ ] and mildew and
piss and always has the science like
please clean up after you're done nobody
does and there's just miles of [ __ ] yeah
so they posted this on their Instagram
skills yeah what kind of skills are they
expecting I don't know what other
techniques are there you're just saying
to be creative and submit yourself with
that hashtag oh your drumming up
height for the business is smart dude a
hundred bucks an hour for internship you
know what there's always greet each dog
that comes in and I pet them or whatever
and the goal is to get these dogs to wag
every time they see the host the the pup
turn what if it hazard pay like all cuz
you might get bit might get bit
so the hundred bucks an hour is it's
just in case [ __ ] happen I'm down dude I
take a hundred bucks a day I thought it
should be hazard pay when just working
at Applebee's doing the same door
greeting thing you can get bit there I
feel like you've worked at Applebee's
you have that look thank you that'll be
lit but but I know people never never I
think you're gonna make it you're not
missing out no I didn't know that there
was someone greeting you that's my oh I
see yeah he got good diet food like the
you know they always have those smart
choices like those things under like six
and the colors yeah I have those deals
too that's the opposite of those smart
choices yeah hamburger fries in the
milkshake and then an apple pie for
$8.99 on Friday
yeah holy [ __ ] like how come McDonald's
employees don't get hazard pay do they
they talk about getting bit dude those
people actually that's true
that's a hard life cost oh I like that
girl they're going to fight with that
drunk girl yeah you see that tweet the
[ __ ] Kanye put out that he like
McDonald's his favorite restaurants and
the burn king tweeted back he goes it
makes sense social accounts [ __ ]
tight oh don't shade it I like that [ __ ]
Burger King yeah I missed the king that
was creep like a rapist though it was so
funny though I liked it like when people
turn over in their bed and then he's
next to them like yeah that's creepy
he's not saying anything jack is my dude
Jack he's a family man he seems like a
family man I think a standard I like
when they would change his like
expression humor no you actually has a
kid to remember the little kid little
Jack I don't know he has a wife too and
everyone forgot about the mad cow [ __ ]
that happened with Jack in a box did
y'all ever get that jack-in-the-box
thing and put it on your tent on your
car no I thought that was done we had a
fuse
I don't have antennas anymore no no not
really
plastic yeah be kind but I think I
didn't do it because I didn't have that
I thought done I had a new rare car I
wonder if I would have do these places
make money though like dog boarding and
all that but if they're making money
through the restaurant and bar that's
even smarter [ __ ] yes you you want a
place where you could just chill with
your dogs and stuff
obviously that just looks like a place I
see this overly visit one of our former
athletes in Colorado and there's a place
it's how about yard house yeah all kinds
of beer all kinds of food and there's an
entire outdoor place where you could
play either cricket or what's that that
beanbag throwing game you know oh yeah
feedback cause I hate that one but
there's that game like darts like things
that you can actually don't interact
with the game that's a drinking game ya
know so what what that would be they
added alcohol to it but you play it with
just your friends and it's like this
wooden sliding thing and you like throw
at each other I don't know
yeah but it's like it's like it's it's a
it's a place where you can get physical
and interact with your buddies yeah
there's like horseshoes yeah do they
have horseshoes there instead of just
sitting there and drinking with your
friends but they have that a lot in bars
dude really it hella breweries they have
that they have it literally at our
office the brewery there they have games
there yeah bro
Wow must be missing out yeah angel house
brewery on LA there's a few of them oh
maybe it's the environment that you're
talking about how bigger it is
everywhere else the coolest backyard
game I've ever seen in my life I was in
Singapore and they we're at this hotel
and they had gigantic Ginga oh it was
like 9 feet tall that's tight yes right
so there's an actual punishment for
[ __ ] up Aegina not just like oh my
tables and so you should watch our JK
party video where we have a punishment
every time you pull some [ __ ] out that
one is crazy I'll play the 9 foot one
any day versus the [ __ ] JK party one
I don't know how long I don't scary that
could be fun wait tell you now that
yeah well over the end it's just a
punishment the whole time no matter what
you can't win at all yeah and then I'm
[ __ ] all over baby IQ because that
in itself was a punishment game and then
ants like do don't show on the game man
oh my dude just playing this game was a
punishment that's a good shoutout to all
of you that have been sending us the
baby emoji you guys made it and [ __ ]
I know I was tripping out I was like
what's happening there's so many baby
emojis and then someone finally
commented like we made it to the end I'm
like to me into what it must be a video
and then I was like deducing all these
things I'm like oh JK party cool you
guys did it and and can officially dicks
cuz the what the joy that people got
from that video was watching the shell
over it dead wrong eat dicks like with
dogs no but I want this business like I
wanna if I if I were to retire that's
like a combination of having like a dog
what do you call it like a refuge but
also having like a cool little
restaurant and bar I love the one like
there's those especially like those
hipster ass places where the it's a
restaurant and you could bring your dog
in and they have like the outdoor patio
and they even have like the little dogs
menu like little like chicken theme for
the dog ball the water or whatever for
the dog do when I worked at maker
studios everyone brought their [ __ ]
dog in it was so annoying you're in a
meeting with people and it's like under
the table like little monsters over
there like it was weird dude yeah it was
just and if you're in Silver Lake or if
you're in Culver City now every
restaurant I feel like has dogs every
[ __ ] where before we had Tiger we'd
bring the dogs office all the time yeah
[ __ ] and piss everywhere I want to be
the guy who like wears I don't know like
a fat guy who wears an overly tight Star
Trek was a t-shirt and he goes to arrest
like this with an iguana on Alicia those
people you're just doing it for
attention at this point this is why I
doesn't give a [ __ ] about you why are
they all the same type of person no I
hate it and it's like I saw on that the
the guano is hanging from the back of
his [ __ ] collar and he looked like
that yeah
it's not the same thing he's a bird he
has a little bird maverick maverick yeah
oh I thought it was your friend well he
he yeah you didn't bring up the bird
birds are the worst dude have you seen
guys with birds on their shoulder they
had their back is full of [ __ ] I love a
[ __ ] talking parrot though the ones who
swear openly yep I love though I'm a kid
see any racist term and it's just
hilarious look at that bird it's not
because then you're like who the [ __ ]
thought this [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
he you and you don't the awesome trainer
yeah exactly the trainer who's like
snickering in the corner I think it's
him you know [ __ ] losing his [ __ ]
mind over there
[Music]